الاشادات تنهال على اسود الاطلس دي شويه
يتفادى الحديث عن بنزيما ومانشستر سيتي
الاكثر استفاده من المونديال هذه الاخبار
وغيرها تتابعون على العربيه رياضه اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد الانجاز الذي تحقق في كاس العالم
انهالت عبارات المديح والاشاده بمسيره
المنتخب المغربي في المونديال خاصه بعد
المباراه البطوليه التي قدمها اسود الاطلس
امام منتخب فرنسا الذي يعتبروا ابرز
المرشحين للفوز بكاس العالم وتتبقى مباراه
وتحديد المركز الثالث امام كرواتيا وهي
فرصه ثانيه على المنتخب
يوم السبت المقبل
بعد انتشار صور بنزيما في تدريبات تعالت
بعض الاصوات المطالبه بضمهم مجددا لمعسكر
المنتخب الفرنسي وخلال المؤتمر الصحفي
الذي اعاقب نصف النهائي تفادديشون حديث عن
هذا الموضوع الذي يبدو انه شكل صداعا في
راس المدرب الفرنسي
كما اعلن اديشن خلال المؤتمر الصحفي عن
اجتياحي فيروس غريب حسب الفريق واصبح نجم
بايرن ميونخ
كينجو
تخوفه من اصابته لاعبين اخرين بهذا
الفيروس قبل النهائي الحاسم ضد منتخب
الارجنتين
اصبح مانشستر سيتي اكثر نادي استفاده
ماديا من مشاركه لاعبي في كاس العالم و
سيدفع الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم نحو خمسه
ملايين دولار للفريق الانجليزي وسيوزع
فيفا حول 180 مليون دولار على الانديه
نظيره مشاركه لاعبيها في البطوله بمعدل
10,000 دولار لكل لاعب في اليوم الواحد
[موسيقى]